welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz
today I'm in sunny Birmingham in the
jewelry quarter never been here before
and I'm joined by Chris stringer who is
the owner of that recruitment company
and they specialize in the IT
development market and only operate in
the Netherlands and German markets Chris
hello Johnny Mae no worries so as I was
saying we're always like to start on
this podcast is how you got into
recruitment and then we'll we'll
definitely be focusing on your business
journey okay so how did Chris string it
into the world of recruitment home so I
long story short dropped out of
university because I'd spent all my
money and left to be a double glazing so
Aspen well and that's how it sort of
came about I seriously ran out of money
in my first term and a little leaflet on
the floor saying earn many quit ring
this number odd and didn't know what it
was or anything went down to this random
little Industrial Estate in Lincoln and
it turned out to be a double glazing
company and they wanted us to call make
the appointment really reps to go around
one minute sets up yeah basically that's
what it was and they targeted me like
half half Ally to whatever that is I
still don't know what I used to this day
and my first day I've got four and okay
right and think about doing sales before
so I ended the first year I work more
went to uni less end of the first year
failed because when he left and then
when I got sick of kind of making my mom
cry because her firstborn was a double
glazing salesman I really do need your
parents know that you're doing yeah they
weren't happy I was doing criminology
and English language and all of a sudden
the future is PVC so no so yeah I got
offered a job in Birmingham failed the
first year and never went back and then
thought well I need to actually get a
job didn't know what I could do got
offered loads of jobs ambulance-chasing
so have you had an accident or selling
photocopy a toner I really don't want to
do this and then thought well
recruitment sounds alright but I wasn't
a graduate it was 2006
and nowhere I'd let you in so really no
no no it's all agree I was I was
[ __ ] I was 19 at the time I was 21 I
started but unless you're a degree
holder they wouldn't look at you so I
sent off a load of application saying
look just give me some advice
and somebody luckily an internal
recruiter from s3 phone me up gave me 30
seconds and that was it all of the
brand's said no except progressive and I
went and started they're kind of
engineering division because my old
man's an engineer and I think they're
quite like I said what she was like what
it was actually I'll just assume that
yeah she's like right Chris you got
failure you face a second literally 30
seconds why do you want to be in
recruitment and which I still do now so
yeah we do we did that and yeah okay so
it's a frame-up then so join the
infamous s free and then use there was
it for six no no three and a half years
I spy was their first hiring their new
kind of engineering engineering okay are
you there for three and a half years
then you join another business during I
became a bit of a recruitment [ __ ] to
be honest unfortunately yeah because he
we did s three recession recruiting an
engineer in 2008 2009 it was harder for
me it came to the point where I needed
to try something else went and joined a
company over in Dudley and didn't do
very well at all that was that was a
huge failure but it teaches you and then
fell into doing Amsterdam recruitment
and kind of here we are now with an
office in Amsterdam and one in Berlin so
yeah that's the route into it yeah so so
just a frame mark for everyone listening
so yeah go into recruitment see how long
we've been in recruitment now first
scene oh my god recruitment yes I was
like a hundred thirteen and a half years
earlier is now 33 33 right so
recruitment 13 years started s free
went to another business and then you
started your own business yeah well oh
there was another one there was another
one in between one of them one yeah I
was one of them for a little bit well
I've got to do something
no but the the the the story of it is my
first job I loved it a really yeah I
mean it wasn't so much the just the way
that it was there the kind of culture
they had I was one of those geeks that
on a Sunday night I really wanted to get
back into work and what going and
working for a few businesses and seeing
how they operate you don't necessarily
get that in every business so I wanted
to create a business again where it was
an exciting place and you look forward
to going we're not there yet we're
getting there but where you'd be excited
to go back into work and that was it
started just to cook one before we dive
into sort of you and your business like
I'm always curious because again when I
moved up to London and that's when I
first heard of brands like s free and
soar just been in this recruitment world
right so I'm always keen like how how
how how do you would you describe that
culture because obviously a lot of
people speak with your Harley of its
created loads of business owners and
loads of really successful people in
industry like if you were talking
someone down the pub lever and they're
gonna what was s free like how how would
you describe that culture I think it was
perfectly acceptable to go through every
kind of emotion every single day and the
lows are so low and the highs are so
high and that I mean that's consistent
in every recruitment job but what they
had there and I'm going back and I sound
like the typical xs3 boy going back but
what they had there was like a culture
where it was kind of expected to do well
but it was competitive but it was
supportive at the same time all the good
stuff that you hear but you had fun you
made friends I still speak to be near
now that I'm worked with for ten years
yeah because everybody was like minded
and they they got that side of it really
right the people they got for the door
and then the managers I mean they
trained you really well yeah they do
that I still use some of those training
sessions today the managers they're
genuinely wanted you to at least in my
case I learned from the best and they
wanted you to do well so you end up
being very loyal to it and the people
that are loyal tend to do well it's an
engagement thing the more engaging you
are the better you're gonna do and yeah
so just to sort of finalize that just
always interested in this because again
thinking of Solway but we were talking
about this before but like
young in your career then did you get
exposed to like really high hairs like
big bitters yeah and I wasn't well
that's what I mean like how do you but
I'm just interesting that because it's
like I've quoted a couple of times now
but I really like the quote it's like
you can only be what you see mmm I think
that's a really interesting thing to
think about in recruitment right I think
of my recruitment career the top Villa
was doing the circle 200k run that
mmm-hmm to think to think beyond that
and go yeah there's perm recruit is out
there billion 300k or whatever like how
can even think now if you can see it I'm
like how did that how did being exposed
to that I don't know how was that for
you you see in that the I think with
anything your mind say in any kind of
business is infectious isn't it so if
the company is running in a positive way
where people are kind of expected to do
well then it's it's contagious people do
do well the opposite is also true
but I think investor I mean I wasn't a
terrible biller by any stretch but I
never did the four or five 600's that
you see there I think the mindset it
kind of gets you into if you think
certainly as a poem recruiter that your
month hasn't started until we've done
two or three yeah then incident down
you're gonna be shooting for four of
like if you're lucky if you sat there
and you're thinking well I really opened
do one this month you're just gonna get
rid of it just call veyts your standards
to be high the bars higher because you
yeah that's very competitive you want to
be the best you see people who are
putting money to one side for one minute
I know that's a lot of people's
motivation never really was mine but the
barometer for success and and the
feeling that you get looking around
going there's good people here and I'm
mixing it with the best of them they
really highlighted that radio and it's
something that I've tried you take to
every company as well that's interesting
okay so your own recruitment business
mmm-hmm it's been going now for six
years six years yeah how do you always
wanted to do any business mmm no but I'd
always have designs of maybe doing
something myself and then when when I
did go to a couple of businesses I
thought well I need that birds I need
that spark and need that passion
something that I can
grow and really not have to answer to
anybody actually after a little while
and put your own stamp on things and
that's that's why I kind of got into it
and had and do you thing was there any
one sort of personal to you that you
think influenced you and when
one-in-seven around business or was it
just through your sort of recruitment
career where you got exposed to
entrepreneurs and things of that or I've
been really lucky with some of the
people that I've worked with and some of
the network that I've grown but I think
actually looking at things I've got kind
of the mission statement of our business
is continual improvement always looking
to do things better and and I think if
you if you're in somebody else's arena
for a long period of time you're not
comfortable to step out and say this is
how we improve things let's look at
innovation here so I always wanted to be
able to put my own model to do or do it
a bit better and I think that's where it
came from it was a natural conclusion
yeah okay cool
that recruitment company mm-hmm where
did that come from
I stole if you want the honest yeah
there was no I don't even like you
bought the domain no no no there was a
restaurant growing up Star City in
Birmingham when it was a kid and it was
called that Mexican place and I thought
well that's clip and I thought I'm
having that so something that I do it
just always stuck with me and I'm not
very inventive and the company culture
is kind of what you see is what you get
so you might as well call it a
recruitment company think that's where
that came okay cool
so what how would be good to break down
there this the last six years so let's
definitely talk about the first year I
think if you think about people
listening that made long term inspires
have their own business or are going are
in their own business right now
the first year as we know a lot of
people fail right so that first year in
his business firstly to frame-up was it
just you yes just additional fashion
well I took my first member of stuff on
Sam when 10 months in yes the first 10
months just Chris like dog yeah did you
have any sort of strategy I think so I
think you you kind of know the direction
where you go where you're heading
towards you've always got to have a plan
in place but it is a little bit of
let's do our very very best and try and
keep everything sharp and then we'll
make some decisions when there's some
cash in the bank
yeah and that's that's really where it
eats started but he's terrifying I did
it with seven grand and in my back
bedroom in my house to start to say you
did it at home yeah yeah - start off but
I turn my my bat room into an office and
I only went in there to work yeah first
it can be quite hard to blend that when
you're at home and it's all-encompassing
especially when you start and off and
you're looking to get your first few
deals in or you first couple of fees and
take the pressure off yourself you just
don't stop and it's it's healthy to a
point but it can easily overtake and yes
it's finding that and I think a lot of
people will be worried about how they're
going to acquire clients don't want to
piss her previous employers off and
disrespect any covenants and stuff like
that so yeah how so had you done the
Amsterdam or Berlin market previously
yeah I'd worked in Amsterdam and to be
fair I stopped by my covenants my old
company were good to me and and the
covenants always always wary of yeah but
it was also a fresh start and it was an
opportunity to veil things and do your
own under your own banner and the way
that you want to do things so it was a
nice feeling to go out there and build
it as look this is a new brand this is
what we're gonna try and do it was a
totally different experience than just
sitting there on an account how did you
get those clients on cold calling like
literally going back to basics it's the
only thing I think you can do yeah you
haven't got the money to invest in the
tools let's be honest
did you yeah and it was it was it was
only totally invested that LinkedIn
recruiter that was the only thing you
recruited do you have a CRM
yeah a CRM which we still use today
actually I think it's important to lay
your foundations here at least so I used
the initial money to get myself a good
set of tools because I actually have
seen a few businesses that haven't spent
enough yeah it's it's good to be savvy
but you've also got to set yourself up
if you're if you're trying to make a
living and you've got no more resources
to do the job and then the clients that
you're recruiting for it's not gonna
work out so well
but it's good to think about as well
like what like where you're heading and
where you want to be like when you're
making those decisions on should I get a
CRM well actually in twelve eighteen
months time I
thing that I've got more people and
there's gonna be a sorry do you know
it's good to make decisions on well
actually this is where I'm going or
where I want the business to be going do
you go absolutely and I think early
doors you've got to make a decision yeah
whether it's going to be a lifestyle
business or whether you want staff yeah
the first month you go without shaving
for a little bit and grow your hair it's
the stuff you haven't been able to do
but after that it's like I always wanted
to grow and yeah absolutist in in the
right tools and techniques was really
important yeah so cold : then so did
you'd quite this has happened quite a
few times so be interested to see if you
did the same like quite a few people
have said that they went through their
LinkedIn connections I've gone right who
can help me and like send out quite a
few messages and go and look just start
my own business this is what I'm doing
let me know if I can help you ever yeah
did you do that a little bit
I'd to do the the quirky thing to start
off with which we still are a bit quirky
and try and give yourself a bit of
impact in a a bit of branding I think
he's so important but initially I think
everybody looks for the low-hanging
fruit yeah and I think that's and learn
that the kind of not all business that
you're gonna get in his good business so
you'd go and you get you first sort of
offers that go on hold or yeah you go
for whatever you can get and then after
that you think well actually it's going
okay let's try and put some more
strategy and and break these bigger
clients because actually you have a lot
of freedom when you're first starting
out so some clients really like that and
it's just going and finding those people
through networking how how long did it
take is before you made your first deal
I was lucky I started in the July and I
did my first deal in the August really
yeah I was reading but I've always found
that being able to buy food he's a
pretty good motivates you to do your job
okay cool so then and then what what
what did you do billions wise in the
first year then see I split it up
because so started in the July 9 ta from
the July to the December yeah and then
started afresh started afresh in the
January so it's a 90 so and so yeah so
by that point you hadn't made your first
hire no yeah so I'm assuming are quite
that's all right actually you know what
let's let's get some other people
involved yeah you get to a point where
you're kind of thinking well okay it
doesn't feel like your money it still
doesn't today it still feels like I work
for this business yeah like that's
important do get to the point where it's
like I could probably make a higher now
when we're not going to be living under
a bridge so yeah it's just natural
progression is how it goes forward I
suppose so
nany K let's just talk about that and
then we'll progress on to like then get
another person their business stuff like
that but not okay in your spare bedroom
office
not bad right it's all right okay no I
mean because I think that it's good to
talk about I know it's not all about
numbers and all that but a lot of people
have no idea how much they're gonna bill
in that first year that's a real concern
right and I think it's happened quite a
lot now where people being surprised as
to what they've been able to do so I
guess what were what do you think were
the biggest challenges during that
period because you spoke about quite
positively and the unlikely operation
quite smart way but 90 grand in that
period like what were the biggest
challenges do you think the you
literally make every mistake you're ever
going to make and there's nobody I tell
you one really big challenge actually
thinking about it you want it when that
first deal goes in you want to turn
around and kind of high-fiving nah you
could do it and there's nobody there
yeah and it's really that that was a
really hard challenge and I remember
ringing my dad and saying daddy it's
working and he's got no idea about it
didn't understand what what the gravitas
was what the drop/add period was but you
needed some kind of validate and he's
obviously been very supportive but you
need that validation and it's like okay
they'll get back to work then a nice
actress yeah it's difficult it's all
about and then you got a family I've got
a little girl and a wife yeah so like
what how was your wife during this
period well she wasn't she was my
fiancee at the time and I basically did
the deal with her that we'll just see
where it goes and fingers crossed we're
really gonna make a go and I'm sure she
was happy with you she was yeah she's
always been nothing but she puts up with
a lot um so yeah she she was really
happy but I think there is that
disconnect between it sounds like play
money doesn't it we're gonna say 90k
from the
bedroom but it's not knowing what you're
gonna do with that and where you're
gonna invest in and I think that's there
so whilst it was kind of like we can
breathe we can buy groceries happy days
it was always gonna that was the start
we were always gonna push that up like
that cool so let's talk about year two
and three then so brought on what was
his name Sam he did you work from did
you work together no no no I took you
from erect Iraq really and my first ever
hostile rhetoric one of the messages
that I always get is particularly of
businesses where you're at smaller grown
businesses look we're in Birmingham and
there's a lot of other businesses when
it's saturated is competitive water wars
herself to him to join you on this like
well how did you do it how did you get
that I think a big part of what I've
always had is a lot of passion for what
I'm doing here and like I say and it
sounds cliched it's not a money
motivator I always wanted to build
something special and I think some kind
of believed in that he would he'd not
done recruitment before he'd done a
little bit of sales because he wanted to
get into recruitment and if you hear
that from the rookies la Wow but it was
a massive gamble for him and for me
and so far I mean he's probably one of
the best builders I've ever really yeah
he's still here now and kind of yeah so
and then I'm assuming when you took him
on you moved out of there yeah we moved
to this build in a smaller unit in this
building and that was challenging as
well really and tried to do the office
up nice and just the two of us sat there
every day
making him work really hard really hard
that was a challenge that really well
you've got to be you've got to play
every role so you've got to be the best
friend the psychologist the role model
the person who gives him a bollock in
and he put up with a lot and I think
he's worked really really hard to get
where he is but he had really good
training because he sat next next to me
as well yeah that's it that's for me
when I was considering what type of
recruitment businesses to join that's
what really dreaming because I went from
like a bigger corporate company in
insurance and joined a smaller business
as well actually if I get direct access
to you the owner
there's
loads I can learn about you and that
seems to be quite compelling for a lot
of people they give direct access to you
yeah and also when you're working around
suit sucks off like you can see where
your works go in and like it's click
being closer to you is definitely a good
thing and can keep him motivated yeah I
mean he'd probably Hawk you differently
under stress yeah but I think it was
made clear very early there and I do
still do with people who come into the
business now this is a partnership thing
it's not the Christian of recruitment
companies something that I want I want
everybody to be a part of and to help
grow and he's put it with a lot but he's
also turned into one of the best there
is so it kind of works both ways so year
to them was it just like give me a bit
of the timeline so it's just you to make
me think that it was just us two for
about six months and then we went
through a kind of procession of making
hires that weren't the best
I used to treat this job like the
somebody put it to me like this the
driving test is the only test you're
ever going to take where when you've got
in the car you've passed it and it's
your job to fail it right and I used to
treat my job interviews like that so
anybody who was coming in because we
were small and because I didn't have
much of an embryo was giving the job to
anybody who came for it really and you
learned pretty quickly that that's not
good and then what was that because you
felt like way it was in your business
journey that if anyone would consider
working for you you'd be like really
grateful for that and like that
you haven't from that place yeah you do
and and you think there's a bit of
self-doubt where you think well we've
got I've got to just take what I can get
yeah and there's also a little bit of
arrogance which I've learnt now but at
the time because we'd gone in and done
well and some was had been flying I was
sort of thinking well I can teach
anybody to do that's not like that right
so but initially yeah we took on a few
few not-so-good hires and as you do
throughout the years but we've always
steadily grown we've got some really
really great business okay cool so to
end the year to then what what we're
looking at there like you took another
person on how did you remember how much
you didn't you let's see
I think I'm not gonna hold your turn no
it's okay I think we've done between
four we'd done best part 400 I think but
that was mainly a split between Sam and
I when we'd done that and some Chinese
that were coming up so I think we were
kind of thinking well this is going and
we just need to add a hundred of the
right people and we're still looking for
yeah so it seems like since that's all
year - and where you are now at she's
been real organic and building around
you yeah yeah the chap will see that you
bought in and there's been not quite
organic around it has been we do take on
the odd experience tire as well but I
think it's really important that you've
got your own culture and your own brand
and and people believe in it buy into it
and we found that if if you can do that
through organic growth then then why
wouldn't you it's giving people the
opportunity to get involved and have
their say into something and that works
for experienced builders as well we've
got some great experience tires too but
I always think you're gonna love your
first recruitment job more than any
other
so I excites me to be able to teach them
yeah okay cool so look with that then so
let's bring it up to sort of now in this
period then like what because you
mentioned around the hiring and learning
through that quite a bit so I begin to
just speak about that because again one
of the most common messages I get is he
shall mine love - for you to talk to
people about how they've got better at
making the right decision hiring people
and stuff like that right spoken a lot
about this on this podcast but it's just
just so ironic the recruitment business
fine it's light so you mentioned there
was a year - you went through people
learning these sorts of things so be
good just to talk a bit about yeah like
what over the last six years like what
have been this all key learnings on
getting the right people for the door
having a better chance of getting the
right people through what been the
learnings there I think it's it's not an
exact science
yeah I think you have to accept that
it's not an exact science and you are
gonna make great hires and you're gonna
make bad hires and sometimes you you
take a punt and it works
the times it just confirms everything
you already knew that there's no hard
and fast rules I think you've got to
look for synergies within your approach
and actually think about what their what
their introduction into the business is
going to be so we got it wrong and still
do with quite a few of the people that
we brought into our business because
they're their journey their kind of
roadmap into recruitment wasn't as good
as I thought it was okay
and I think it's all very well and good
as an agency owner to sit there and say
well everybody shared we're gonna get a
50% conversion on whatever but unless
you're doing the best that you can for
those people which is an ever-evolving
process then you can't just label people
as as bad hires we've never had anybody
who's consistently been coming in late
bad attitude we've never had that
because you're talking about having not
having the right roadmaps for people in
terms of their career it's what you do
with them everything comes in as a blank
canvas and I think as much as you are
going to get the occasional bad hire
slip through the net it does happen you
also have a duty to them as an employer
to make sure that they come down with
the softer London as possible but
actually learn quickly that you get out
of this job what you put into it and
it's it's it works both ways how how how
look you're a small grown business right
so there's what 13 have you now yeah 12
13 yeah so how can you how water sort
sort of roadmap on their recruitment
career can you offer when you're a small
business like that you know I mean
because it's it's pretty it's gonna be
pretty flat right is it I mean I don't
that's what I mean that's what I be keen
to know like how what sort of things you
speaking to people about on that this is
where you are now
like these are the things that I think
we could we could do for you because
you've got to think about like that what
everyone wants career progression buy it
yeah so that how have you conveyed that
what are the sort of roadmaps that
you've created for people I think just
using a recent example over over the
Christmas period that we've just had
rather than me going right visions 2020
we want to be a x-amount business what
what we did instead was I asked
everybody to write their own Job
Description love so come back in to me
in January with a list of this is what I
gave I hire you this is what I can
expect from you but what do you want
where do you words and that's awesome
and then we build
around those people so when you say it's
got to be pretty flat I mean it can be
but if you want to take it somewhere I
want to help you kind of achieve that I
love that that's what I was trying to
get because it's like someone maybe
listen and go well yeah we're in the
ruinous box room it's like what can i
how can I offer progression to someone
but it's exactly what you just said it's
like you're giving it your pandan over
the bat to someone else I'm gonna let
how how do you want your job to yeah
exactly and cultivate an ass I don't
interested in oh I wouldn't say we get
it back yeah that's interesting it helps
it doesn't it's the Steve Jobs LinkedIn
quo isn't it doesn't make sense to hire
smart people and then tell them what to
do you want to hire smart people and let
them have some impact and influx in
where their career goes and that's what
we kind of subscribe to so do you have
any non-negotiables now then when you're
hiring people like you or do you have
you sort of come up with a betrayer kind
of a bit like non-negotiables it's it's
more a kind of gut feel than we get in
our business people we we don't like
people too much they're they're bounced
around it's not really a wide boy kinda
yeah company I like people who can kind
of demonstrate some motivation so I
asked a lot of people in interview what
did you do the weekend and the ones that
get up at two o'clock in the afternoon
and they're probably a no-go
so just activity and a bit of passion
that's what really shines okay mate cool
so um so in terms of like year by year
then mate how is it being like growth
wise because it'd be interesting we're
talking about a lot about hiring but
obviously we were having a chat before
this and you've been quite pleased with
like how it's continued to grow as a
business right yeah and I think again on
the sort of hiring tangent I think what
can be quite difficult for a lot of
people is sort of getting better at
noticing and picking up on those hiring
triggers mm-hmm so obviously there's
gonna be there's gonna be when you're
bringing people in and that's going to
mean typically you're gonna have to
invest more in them which means maybe a
year and a half time I'm gonna really
see the benefit of that and you get what
I mean yeah what so obviously you've
continued to grow this business in terms
of the performance of the people in here
mm-hmm but yeah how how have you got
better at making the decisions on rakhi
less actually invest in our people now
on strike
I don't know start bringing the next
person etc I think the beauty of having
a business that grows is that obviously
you've got more people on the ground
that doing the job so the the variety of
kind of clients and business that you
bring in creates more need so rather
than just thinking well this guy's good
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna take a pun
on it we'll stick him somewhere you can
look at markets and look at the kind of
roles that you need fill in okay and
look for that certain kind of person
that you need to bring in to fulfil that
role so make sense so so recognising the
platform that you can offer a one sort
of yeah so if we if we interview
somebody who's very intelligent very
well-spoken very formal we now would
have a senior appointments desk where
they might fly better then then kind of
a the digits on the media side which is
kind of very informal and very relaxed
so there's more opportunities for more
people it's not just a one size fits all
you've got to look at your business kind
of objectively and if you've got
somebody in front of you you've got a
kind of a responsibility of as an
employer to then turn around think well
can I offer this person a good home not
just yeah oh this is gonna be like good
biller and that's enabled you to yeah
when and you're thinking about that when
you've got people in front of you which
is which
yeah gives you a better chance of okay
yeah that makes sense yeah because you
want to set these people up yeah there
every every hire that we've lost it's a
lot of investment a lot of time and it's
upsetting it's it's a bruised ego so you
want you don't set people up to fail you
set them up for success but as you do
kind of get bigger and gather some
momentum there's more opportunities for
you to put the right people and so you
can you can make those are you actively
looking for that for that like before
you have Jan I mean is it is it both
ways where like because yeah so are you
like actively looking for those
opportunities within your business and
then you've got that then in mind when
you've got people sitting in front of
you I mean is it both there's a bit of
both yeah but because yeah so that's
interesting yeah yeah I think you meet
you need to know what your business
needs
yeah and that's whether it be revenue
business developers resources account
managers you need to know what that is
at the same time if you
got somebody sat in front of you and you
think wow this is a this is a Super
Start then you sometimes you don't know
and you've got to give those people the
opportunity as well it's just been open
race what's your what's your mindset to
growing this business now on I know it's
not all about headcount right I think
Matt said it like I would say head
counts just vanity right and it's about
maximizing the the people in your
business and there's everyone sort of
things but it's come up a couple of
times unlike as you've grown this
business like how have you have you had
the mentality of always hiring that's
that make sense so are you someone
that's always willing instead of being
reactive I'll actually know what often
there's opportunities for the senior
appointments desk now I'm gonna start
hiring let the rhetorics know all have
you always had the mindset of always
willing to go meet people for a coffee
or do you not I mean how sorry sorry to
sit on the fence but I think he's both
we're always hiring but we're hiring for
the right people near and there's times
where we've kind of hit okay well we've
got some people that need to come in
before we hire again and then there's
somebody who comes past your door and
you think I've got to have that person
it's it's really the best of both worlds
it's just interesting because I think
spoke a lot about hiring but I think
that is obviously a really big challenge
when people trying to grow their
businesses and I think it's happened
it's come up quite a lot that people
really just approached it on this sort
of always hiring mentality rather
whereas previously they've been a bit
prone to being reactive which can
sometimes enable you or encourage you to
make bad decisions because you're like
making short-term decisions yeah my
sense and I think it's important that
it's not a battle that you'll ever
conquer in your business is going to be
a great hire but what you can do is try
and put the best caliber of person that
you can possibly find in a room with a
load of other really high caliber people
and really hope that just chemistry
happens and guide that and I think it's
as much about that really as mist and
being a bit of an opportunist rather
than saying well I need X this X skill
and X background and so just a frame art
for people mate because I'd love to just
dive into some of the key things that
you've gone through that you think have
had a quite significant impact on
helping you guys to get to where you are
now on a nice
whatever but so year-on-year then has it
been grow feeling yeah we've liked
revenue yeah revenues growing every year
some years we've doubled some years
we've we've added a minimum of forty
percent revenue was we've always added
headcount on per year as well I think
this year might be slightly different I
think we might have a bear of a
consolidation year and just make sure
that everything is really bullet proof
so that we can then explode but yeah I
think we grow year on your growth is an
important marker okay and okay cause so
that there wasn't so there what I'm
thinking about is so last year it's been
a year on year on growth I guess any key
things for you that sort of in hindsight
where six years in had a really good
year last year that you think have sort
of been significance you've been odd to
hit those numbers and things that you've
achieved yeah it's a very cliche dancer
but I think if I was to do it all again
I'd do everything differently because
you have to go and earn your scars and
and really really learn from that but I
think not being so scared initially to
to spend money because the reason you
start a business is because you're
you're good at this right and you're
confident that you you can kind of step
out on your own and I think there's so
many good tools about now that will help
you tie card row like the certain crms
that do really well if you invest in
those tools it's it's a license to make
money and also I think just letting
people have a little bit of freedom
because you take everything very
personally when it's your own trust me
and I'm a control freak and I'm still
work you have to get better at just
letting go letting go in front and
realizing that actually my business has
some buckle judgment I have some great
people there that can do a pair of that
by them forcing me to today I have a
very open relationship I know I'm not
perfect right so and I know I've got my
flaws and it's about recognition
learning about yourself as well and you
don't want to squeeze you don't want to
be that that little kid with the puppy
that squeezes it so hard that it yeah if
people want to do something and if
they've got an idea and their
motivations
run with it because they they end up be
more proud more bought in and it
benefits the business I wouldn't say
I've got it down pat yeah yeah yeah my
old boss yeah I said before we start a
similar business and yeah we have quite
an eye promotion now and always chat and
it is that like when you're in the role
that you're in now like it's quite hard
to see like how you're gonna be in a
position where you might not be billing
anymore or completely out of it like you
you get pulled pillar to post right yeah
you're so accessible and those sorts of
things so that's interesting so when
people have come up with ideas and gone
Chris you've thought about this blah
blah blah instead of going not sure and
then you you're then really involved
it's gone more actually yeah why not
yeah I need again it's not not something
we've mastered yet but why would you not
do that if somebody comes to you in your
business that says I've spotted this can
I have a look so long as he's not doing
the obvious things like treading on
everybody else's toes and doing more
then yeah do it you never know which
company is going to be the next doober
right you never know which market is
going to be where the newest
technologies come in from so you have to
kind of expand a little bit and evolve
and adapt and keep going with the market
and actually unless you want to do it
all yourself then enabling people to be
able to do that it's a really good way
of developing your business and moving
it forward
I like that so speaking of the market
like how have you found so your business
servicing Netherlands alone Amsterdam
Germany a lot in Berlin
what's that been like because I'll see
you do the UK business right no UK
business yeah again I know we were
talking about this before like a lot of
people may think how could you do that
like in terms of yeah being in the UK
whatever how can you serve a lot of
people outside of the UK and these sorts
of things from the UK like how how's
that generally being for you well I
always say the same thing the job is the
job I can get to Amsterdam as quickly as
you can get to London it's a 40-minute I
still mad that someone law that's like
[ __ ] out 40 minutes like it takes me
longer to get to Berman I really do I
mean I was mad flew back last night and
it's not I'm not broken today we think
of other countries like they're the
other side of the world
not in Tanzania literally like 40-mile
but yeah it it's a difficult one because
it's a culture shock when you first go
into it and there's a lot of especially
English recruitment companies that are
trying to I use a question I get asked a
lot open up in Europe and how do you do
it and it's all well I'm not gonna tell
you a briefly crit but he's a different
culture it's a different way of working
it's hard to adapt to but actually if
you can if you can get in there and get
it done properly it's it's an amazing
among market I'm sure you're willing to
share may be good to know is like what
are the common what other common things
you've seen here quite and quite English
recruiters do wrong when they're trying
to but get into mainland Europe or
whatever that you've typically always
heard about I'm sure that I'd be used
for people this is a weird one right
I'll give you one see the the
misconception is that we're too salesy
into aggressive English recruiters
because we have a really smooth sales
pitch and we're able to really pressure
people and you kind of have to learn a
way to knock all of that aggression out
of yourself and not be seen to be
selling by selling harder than you've
ever sold in you it's quite a difficult
thing to learn so it's very relationship
orientated it's very quality focused if
you over promise and under deliver in
Europe it's in standard rather turn
around to a client and say I will be in
touch in two three weeks but and I will
have one CV then look you're gonna have
three CDs by the end of the day and send
nothing because it's very black and
white yeah in your market so if you say
you're gonna do one thing and do another
you'll reputational a lot more direct
yeah Chris you said you do this and you
haven't yeah and you can manage that
so these expectations management right
so you have to be honest with people
there's nothing wrong with turning
around saying actually I haven't got any
of those candidates rather than well
I've got a database of it's just a good
total different way of doing your
business but it's more collaborative its
relationships are more important their
long-standing some of our clients i i
I've had for six years and have followed
them through various different companies
so that when they know it's you they're
only gonna use you but it does take a
little while to filter bird that course
yeah and how have you again I'm sure a
lot of people think of it in a nutshell
like how have you come up against the
challenges of your UK business would you
say you're pretty much based on most of
the time announcer don't know we're
fairly honest about it
the reason kind of a back story to
initially no but we're fairly honest
because it's the job is the job right
and if we've got the right tools and the
right resources and I can be on site for
10:00 a.m. tomorrow morning why would
you not work yeah I think a lot of
people could just make that assumption
couldn't there that yeah a lot of times
people wouldn't like potentially dealing
with a UK business people don't yes yeah
but then they're the ones where actually
I've always said this your best
relationships start on an argument right
so where you really have to go and
improve why they should be working with
the UK recruiter
it's ah okay and then you do get more
business off the bucket so it can work
for you or against you it just depends
on how you voice it really yeah that's
interesting okay mate so marketing
mm-hmm I think it's fair to say that
you've got a pretty cool brand okay I
think I mean going to our fist green
every way beyond the wall yeah I think I
think when I originally dropped you a
message I think I saw that post around
like the trainer's yeah trainers so I
think look I'd love to get sort of your
experience like you mentioned earlier
around getting better at understanding
the look when we're making money which
means look we're Grannis business
getting better investing it and being
more willing to invest it in the right
things or whatever so what's been your
journey and investing in your brand of
marketing I'm like what how's that been
for you personally in the business so I
think in order to answer that I spend a
lot right I'm a spare I always have been
a spender anyway but I if I'm going to
sit somewhere for work for 35 to 50
hours a week every way I want to enjoy
being that yeah right so only be proud
if I'm going to take somebody show them
the
office or the trainer thing it needs to
be kind of a showpiece that that helps
with your recruitment with regards to
kind of external branding I think you've
got to know what your passion is and
what message you're trying to deliver
and then it becomes a lot easier I think
if you are known for being that that
brand that's not quite corporate but
will still deliver the same result but
do it with a more human touch which is
kind of where we go with it then the
branding kind of writes itself and you
get a lot more freedom don't you yeah so
what you're saying there is knowing what
you are firstly or what you want to be
known yeah and staying loyal to it
you've got to have an idea of what you
want the brand to be or how you want it
to be perceived that's a better way yeah
and then if you know that and if you
really are true to that then the
branding becomes maybe your content I
should say becomes more relevant
slightly easier and how how has
investing in that and going through that
impacts your business minute how does it
I mean it's it's hard to quantify
because we're stuck in it from outside
but we've been noticed too fair for you
to Billups and we've got a bit of a pun
of a name and we try and do things
brightly colored and bold and a little
bit more flashy so it just stands out a
little bit more and all I want to really
do is pique your interest that's it and
if you decide to lift the bonnet up and
have a look in and it works for you and
your business then yeah that's that's a
good way so advice for people that are
hearing more and more from people that
Marx is important and seeing companies
like yours go off Chris is doing like
looks really cool Chris is doing and
stuff like that like any advice for
people that are staying yeah again I
think know how you want your brand
perceived I think you need to
would you buy off yourself and I think
you've the answer so that is no such a
great question
you gotta believe that right I really
have and I think there's a lot of
companies out there that they pick an
object and a color or they pick and two
names and put them together yeah but how
are you gonna get remembered the
memorable bit I mean as he's a bit
cheesy I still shudder a little bit but
I'll say that recruiting are I
in kind what what you stand for what you
want to do yeah it sounds simple but
yeah you've got an you got to make sure
that especially with where your business
right now we've got you've got to be on
the same page if you're gonna start
shouting about it and make more external
noise and stuff like that and it's
easier to keep a consistent approach
with your business then because it kind
of is what it is that make sense yeah
yeah yeah if it's what you see is what
you get it's pretty hard to mess it up
so I just try and keep it simple so
Chris as you as you've been learning
you've been growing this business make
mistakes as you're quite and please
share others like how how have you
managed to get the best out of your
people do you think the people around
you have can because that that's that's
that would have been paramount to
hitting the numbers that you did last
year like how have you got the best out
of your people do you think um I think
you've got to have a shared really
cliche term but it's kind of a shared
vision and I think actually it's okay to
turn around to people and say I'm not
doing very well with this I'm having a
rough day and I've been lucky with the
people that I have they're really I'm
really open about like mental health I'm
an anxiety sufferers stuff like that not
to detract from your question but I mean
very very open book with people so they
know look if we make this amount of
money this is what we're going to do
whether that be an incentive a division
whether they're gonna have a great
paycheck that it's really having that
kind of open forum and being
approachable I think that's really
worked for us because I wouldn't say
anything different to my staff than I'm
saying here now and vice versa but they
then become they don't feel apart they
are a part of what the business becomes
and the kind of feeling that well I hope
they get this they own eight to like
started as a trainee he's now an owner
of the business it's not a false promise
if you work hard then we can make this
the best job in the world for you and
sort of you
yeah covet not open forum not open but
culture is men they're the people that
you do have around you are willing to be
accountable responsible which breeds
yeah better performance I think that
because people willing to because yeah
I'm not doing it just for me it's like
I'm on the journey here with Chris yeah
and I think it's important that
the old cliche is that you see the MD
turning up in a Maserati and then come
in and Pollock in a seventeen year offer
for their phone times like no that's not
it's not the way to do feeling it with
them go you this is properties now
because I'm gonna say the name of your
podcast but he's a recruitment rolling
yeah and we've we've got to be all on it
together yeah but so you mention there
before we start wrapping up mate like
you mentioned then like I always talk
about mindset on this a lot for you well
yeah what has been your journey and sort
of the mental side so you said there the
definitely an anxious person like what's
been the sort of mental journey of
having your own recruitment business and
having other people involved hunts pay
salaries your personal relationships
like how is it because I think again
this is really important to me to talk
about like that and I've we always do on
here so like how was that journey being
for you personally I think when you said
mental we've pretty much something you
you experience every single emotion man
sometimes it's hot you get really easily
wrapped up in stuff I mean when my
daughter came along I hear hear low
looking back probably a burnout why is
that do you think because I didn't adapt
to fatherhood as quickly as I thought
would
business we weren't doing quite the
figures that we're doing now yeah I
tried to take on too much didn't have
the support networks in place that you
haven't had there's loads of stuff you
can do differently but I think overall
you've got to realize the reasons that
you do in this and you've got to look at
the people in your business that
actually they do want to help you and
I've got to plug this a little bit
there's a support network outside of the
business if you look at in Brum the
Canaries are like a huge hugely
important part of having a support
network where you can just go and have a
moan or you can talk to somebody who
owns a business with a hundred people in
it and not keeping it all bottled is
really helpful and and kind of wearing
your heart on your sleeve a little bit
you don't want to leave yourself totally
open at the same time it's ok to say
you're having a tough day you know I
mean and and I used to shy away from
that and now really but having that
support network or as you said I think
that's a good sort of learning there and
what you've experienced is well actually
and I think this is this is the whole
thing right typically a lot of
typically males is like you're not going
to show weakness you're not gonna be
vulnerable but I think that that's the
whole thing that it's quite hard to
shake it off sometimes especially when
your own your own business you've got
people around you've got a show that
sort of well know Chris is alright and
you've got a showcase that sometimes
when sometimes you might not be I think
you win more friends by saying actually
you don't want to be that recruiter in
the perb when you when you bump into an
ex-colleague and it's like how you doing
it's great and you know right know that
yeah and I think it's really important
that you don't you don't paint this
horrible fake picture of yourself and
people want to help you they genuinely
want to help you they want you to do
well there's a couple of exceptions but
they're not the people you talk to other
um and I think it's okay because most of
the time if I'm struggling or if people
come to me who's struggling I've been
through that or they've been through
that and this genuine really good advice
there whether that be within the
business or from the network outside of
it Shay bird and a little bit you've got
to take a bit as well but that's a good
feeling too because you've kind of all
in it and I think particularly as why I
act from you and obviously myself we're
talking about this before that like you
started business on your own right yeah
you've got your employer's over it
obviously mm-hmm and obviously as well
other people that now are in the
business but you're on your own yeah and
and it is quite isolated and being being
honest it still is not so much anymore
because it's the business but yours pin
will become you have you cornerstone so
I always say that but initially yes it's
terrifying genuinely terrifying and you
don't nobody tells you this is a really
really thing I found really difficult
nobody tells you that you're doing it
right people tell you that you're doing
it rock and here everybody's a critic
but nobody goes actually you're doing
okay there and how do you have a
barometer for your own kind of
validation you don't want to turn around
say oh yeah we're doing fantastically
well but at the same time you've got to
stop and smell the roses every so often
nothing and just just to sort of wrap
that up man I'm always curious to hear
people's experience with this because I
think a lot of people and I finish
you're changing but I think a lot of
people for whatever reason particularly
your own your own business made like how
confident are you that if you reach
now for help that someone's gonna be
willing to help you right like so a lot
of people may feel like they're not
gonna help me along would help me or
whatever like what when you have gone
you know I actually I'd love to see if
someone can happen with this or whatever
like what has been your experience when
you have reached out to people I've
never had a negative experience that's
what I mean but a lot of people may in
that person yeah they're too senior for
me or even you're employed this is a
massive one like I've got people who
work in this business are my counselors
a hundred percent I'm quite open for it
but nobody ever turns around going up my
chin up you know but people want to help
and it's really important even as a
recruiter this is not a new thing for me
but it's really important to know that
you willing to help as much as you ask
for help but it's nothing to be ashamed
of and it's okay to but so yeah anyway
yeah anyone listening this light you
know what yeah I'd love to get some help
with that forever you're not sure if you
should reach out to that person like do
it like you be that's me
yeah but that's just come out so often
it's also come up before a lot of
recruiters who have gone right how come
how can I increase my own performance
and those people around them that have
that they look up to and it's like go
ask them be curious and that's like was
when you have your own business you'd be
surprised how many people be willing to
help and you think again going back to
the networks in place when I first
thought about networking again with
Canaries or whatever it is you think I
don't want to be around a loaded dick so
I said it's not like that that's all
like where's your pain points how can we
help you with this and and you've been
through that as well that's a really
important yeah kind of emotion to to
feel because you've realized actually
you're not as isolated as you sometimes
feel mmm I think that's that's where it
is
so look before before we finish and what
what like knowing what you know now
mm-hmm what advice do you wish that
you'd been given early on on this
journey it's a good question don't bite
off more than you can chew and try and
do everything yourself you're not an
island
mmm you can either pay people to help
you or people will just help you yeah
it's okay so have you shitty days yeah
because if you're not gonna have the
shitty days you're not going to
appreciate the good ones that's that's
true
and the final bit I said it earlier not
all business is good business don't
distract yourself working the first
thing that you can find we've all done
it you think it's a golden golden egg
golden opportunity but actually there's
a manager somewhere that that genuinely
needs help and your service and that's
where you'll build your relationship
it's not only not the role that you're
up against 19 other agencies because
they've all pulled it too it's it's
building a good relationship with sort
of reputable businesses that's gonna pay
your bills move it forward
love that mate so what I've been asked
in people over the last couple of weeks
is questions on resilience mmm I'm gonna
vent coming up and it's all about that
what the theme is cultivating resilience
and going the distance it's a couple of
questions for you on resilience what
what does resilience and recruitment
mean to you bouncing back Alan Partridge
no it's the ability to take a bad day
not just blame but actually affects your
environment there's two types of people
right there's people who are controlled
by their environment and people who
control their environment and I think
resilience for me is having the ability
to control your environment and pull
yourself out of it rather than be
controlled by it and let you head it's
been you so when I realized that so
we're talking about there has been a
victim of your circle
realising that you have the you have you
always have a choice how are you gonna
react to this person letting you down
rather than I'm gonna go that person let
me down and pointing the finger right
yeah and it's always somebody else's
fault yeah and you kind of have to let
that go and say well actually what would
I have done different if I run and then
just don't do it again yeah sounds
simple but it's harder than that well
you never finished learning or you know
you get better every single day but if
you if you if you blame or
you not taking the accountability then
this is a horrible job your head goes
down because everybody lets you down all
the time yeah but you got to look in
before you look at anything love that
how has the importance or needs for
resilience changed as the industry's
evolved I think because it still do the
job you have to be more cute now in
whilst cold calling phone bashing it's
really important you've also got to be
brilliant at whatsapp you've got to be
brilliant at Skype you've got to be
accessible 24/7 and I think with regards
to resilience it's very full on now but
you always hear the old-school
recruiters and I'm one of them we didn't
leave the office until 7th no you did
but I'm still on it on my phone and you
probably are as well till like 10 half
10 so you don't get that break anymore
and that can grind you reading it so you
need your resilience to be able to to
keep going yeah because yeah I think
it's really interesting that because
you're you're so accessible now there's
an element of resilience that's required
yeah just if you can't switch your phone
off I wish I could what can people do
themselves to instill resilience in
their teams good question
be more open about when things haven't
gone well I think I think the temptation
is if you've pledged 15 grand a month
and you're in the third week of the
month and you know it ain't coming in
sitting there and pretending that it
still is he's not we've all done it it's
it's not going to help you I think it's
not that these knocks don't happen it's
how you deal with them and be more open
about look this one's messed up and this
month isn't going to be great and
getting some support first of all but
then secondarily kind of following up
with it being okay and looking for to
build on it rather than hide yeah it's a
lie I do yeah as you said again open
forum and yeah yeah even when things
aren't going the right way
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's I think if
you're open about what's gone wrong it's
a it's a much clearer road to get back
if that makes sense so let before I ask
you the last question mate
one what is Chris stringer
excited about me 2020 what's going on
business-wise or everything wanna shout
about my well I think I'd about a market
if you look at that technology internet
of things coming through I've never seen
more cool a kind of millennial type of
companies popping up that are genuinely
making a difference
Europe is incredible as a market to see
the hubs that are going on there with
regards to business we're probably the
strongest we've ever been we're looking
to grow again and it's not showing any
signs of slowing down and just generally
the feeling that we're kind of on to
something I mean I think the first three
years especially you you wasn't
expecting so now I'm kind of
transitioning into into a business yeah
it's a career for people that's exciting
yeah I love that
awesome so the question I always ask
people to finish this is you can answer
it with a phrase or sentence or word
whatever comes to mind but if Chris
could communicate to every single
recruiter out there business owner
they'd listen to advice they'd implement
your advice tomorrow what would you say
to the to the people make keep going mmm
and don't be one of those people that
works the first thing they find because
they're in a hole or they're up against
it you you work the job that every other
recruiters got to keep look at your
business kind of holistic ly take
yourself out of it and see it through a
kind of business managers eyes and is
this really going to achieve the purpose
of what you need this is he gonna get
you to that next step or are you just
working it cuz it's there and it's panic
about the thing that's really important
so a lesson great it's been a pleasure
thank you very much